Musik
Komm zu mir, hör Volkesufu, Volkesufu, hör Volkesufu Podcast-Ufo, höre Podcast-Ufo, Erste? Oh, nee, das will ich nicht sagen. Stefan Serge Tietze. Ja, das ist mein zweiter Name. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ja, wir haben diesen, wir sitzen heute an einem hoch und runter fahrbaren Tisch. Ich weiss nicht, das ist so ein Trend, den beobachte ich häufig bei Leuten, die jetzt gerade auch hier im Homeoffice arbeiten und sowas, bauen sich bei sich zu Hause so einen hoch und runter fahrbaren Tisch hin und stellen sich dann hin beim Arbeiten. Soll wahnsinnig gut für den Rücken sein. Wir konnten den aber gerade runtermachen, aber nicht mehr hoch machen. Richtig. Was dazu führt, dass er und die Patreon-User, die uns auch zuschauen, werden sehen. Wir sitzen, ich sitze wie der Hunchback von Notre Dame, sitze ich wie Quasimodo, habe den grössten Buckel und jetzt frage ich euch, wie soll das gesund sein? Ja, das Problem war, wir konnten es nur runterfahren, nicht hoch. Es war so ein Widerhaken drin, es war wie so eine Falle, wie so diese Kabelbinder, die du immer nur länger ziehen kannst, aber nicht weiter. Und du denkst immer so, komm, ich gebe mir noch einen Noppen, ich gebe mir noch einen Noppen, aber am Ende hast du dich selber gefesselt, musst irgendwie ins Krankenhaus fahren, ich mag das ja auch ein bisschen. Ich sage, ich habe mich selbst geknebelt für eine Masturbation, die am Ende jetzt nicht so viel besser war als sonst, habe ich mich selbst komplett unschädlich gemacht.
Exakt, es ist super gefährlich, diese Dinge, die in eine Richtung gehen, die andere nicht, weil man es ja, ich habe gerade für den Gag und um es dann auszuprobieren, aber auch so ein bisschen, um alles zu sabotieren, mein Leben zu sabotieren, noch mal auf runtergedrückt und zu gucken, ah, klappt der Runterschalter wirklich und der Hochschalter nicht? Ist die Situation wirklich so schlimm, wie ich sie gerade wahrgenommen habe? Ja, ist sie. Genau, und irgendwie habe ich Spaß daran, mehr in dieser Einbahnstrasse hatte ich gerade Spaß daran, mich zu manövrieren. Und jetzt sitzen wir so vorne übergeklappt und ich weiß, dass ich hier nachher mit einem grossen Bandscheibenvorfall rausgehen werde. Ich darf auch mal gross aussehen. Das ist ja, glaube ich, das Gute an diesen beweglichen Tischen, dass man sich auch mal gross fühlen kann. Unfassbar langsam immer auch so. Man sieht das manchmal bei so Streamern, dass die dann den Tisch hochfahren. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Sicherheitsding. So direkt ganz schnell unter den, ja was willst du denn? Ich würde sagen, ich will ja so ein 100 PS Ding, der mir da wie so. Und dann der Laptop und alles, was draufsteht, macht dann so einen Hops, weil das so hoch ist. Aber dann fällt es wieder perfekt, wie es vorher war, genau drauf. Ja, und alle Sachen bleiben dann so oben, genau, wie so ein Comic. Alles wackelt kurz und ist dann wieder perfekt, genauso wie vorher. Super. Das Frühstücksei ist noch genau im Eierbecher. Das Salz ist einmal komplett aus dem Salzstreuer rausgeflogen, aber rieselt wieder exakt durch die Löcher in den Salzstreuer rein. Weißt du, was ich liebe? Stufenloses. Generell stufenloses. Ich habe so viel
Spaß daran bei Devices, die keine
Stufen haben, die zum Beispiel
die Musiklautstärke zu beeinflussen.
Und ich will die perfekt haben,
weil eine Stufe runter und höher, das ist
so locked in. Wo ist das dazwischen?
Ich habe nämlich dann beim, ich weiß nicht, ob es das
jetzige iPhone auch noch hat, aber ein altes
iPhone hatte so Stufen, in denen man so lauter
machen konnte mit den lauter Lasertasten. Und meine Lieblingsingslautstärke habe ich gemerkt, es mag vielleicht auch so eine Einbildung sein, so eine Kontrollverlustangst, lag zwischen zwei Stufen. Ein Nübel runter war zu leise, ein Nübel hoch war zu laut. Du passt nicht ins Raster. Ich passe nicht ins Raster. Das ist wie wenn du eine Pizza bestellst und es gibt drei Grössen und du sagst, nee, ich will noch grösser. Exakt. Ich will eine noch grössere, noch fetter, noch mehr. Wir können noch mehr Käse in den noch fetter, noch mehr. Nach oben. Nach oben. Lass uns in die Z-Achse gehen. Lass uns in die Z-Achse gehen. Wir sind biologische Haufen, individuelle biologische Zellhaufen, aber die Welt um uns herum ist genormt und in Raster und ist nicht stufenlos. Wir aber sind stufenlos.
Ich weiss noch damals an meine Kindheit, und Kindheit war ja geprägt von konstanten Konkurrenzkampf eigentlich, zwischen Cityroller versus Kickboard. Ja, das eine Kind hat ein Kickboard, das andere hat einen Cityroller, zufällig ausgewählt, weil die stockbesoffenen Eltern irgendwie kurz vor Weihnachten, 24.17.30 Uhr,
Oh, ungescheime Florian!
Wie, wir haben drei Kinder.
Schrei mich an!
Ich dachte, wir haben zwei Kinder!
Renate, schrei mich nicht so an!
Verheimnisst du mir wieder unsere Kinder.
Kauf dem dieses Kickboards.
Wer weiss, wer der Vater ist von dem Bängel.
Halt deinen Drecksmaul!
Typ-Modus treffen die Eltern eine Entscheidung, die das Kind für immer prägt. Weil das Kind muss seine Spielsachen verteidigen, auch wenn es es nicht selbst ausgewählt hat. Und er musste sagen, Kickboard Cityroller, warum ist es besser? Ich war Team Cityroller, deswegen habe ich damals den Schmähbegriff Kackboard geprägt, auf den ich bis heute noch recht stolz bin, weil natürlich die Gegenseite City Roller, City Roller, Sissy Roller, keine schlechten Ideen gerade, mal jeder, Jonas, Sissy, was heisst Sissy, die Prinzessin, das ist ein Wort, das kennt man als Kind. Ah, okay, das ist ein Problem, das kennt man gewöhnlich nicht. Das kennt man nicht, nein. Da bist du uns leider schon ein paar Jährchen voraus. City-Roller, Dorf-Roller im Sinne von nicht City, sondern Dorf. Ja, aber wir sind ja auf dem Dorf, aber eben. Roller, Schmoller, Dollar, City-Schmoller. Fuck ey, er hat uns. Wir haben nichts, er hat uns, er hat uns, er hat uns, da muss man auch, und da muss man jetzt die Grösse haben, unsere Niederlage einzugestehen. Jonas, wir haben keine Grösse. Wir sind Kinder, wir haben keine Selbstkontrolle. Ich glaube, das ist dein Problem, du als unser Anführer, dass du keine Grösse hast, dass du das Wort Sissy nicht kennst. Dafür haben wir unsere Kackkontrolle. Er Kick, ach, fuck, ist für immer kaputt. Aber das Kickboard, das war doch das mit diesem Joystick in der Mitte. Genau, mit dem Knobbel. Wie bescheuert ist das denn bitte? Nee, weiter. Ich meine jetzt ernsthaft. Weiter. Wir haben Lenker. Leute, wenn wir so eine Braillefahrt reden. Leute, schaut uns an, wir haben Lenker. Wir können richtig lenken, wie Autos, wie Fahrräder, ja, sogar wie richtige Roller mit Motoren. Ich kann mich bis heute auch noch an alle Argumente erinnern, die da auch immer ausgetauscht wurden. Und die Kackbordfahrer haben dann immer gesagt, ja, wir können zum Beispiel eine Halfpipe fahren, weil wir können unser Vorderrad nicht querstellen. Weil wenn du dein Vorderrad quer stellst, stürzt du und verletzt dich schwer. Fällst zu Boden. Wohin gegen ein Kackbord kann das nicht, weil das nur so hin und her kommt. Sag das jetzt nicht.
Na, der Kampf, ich bin immer noch auf einer Partei. Und ein anderer Kampf war dann zwischen Nintendo DS, Double Screen und der Playstation Portable, PSP. Das habe ich auch gemacht. Und objektiv technisch betrachtet war dieser Konflikt sofort beendet. Denn der Gamba, äh der DS hatte irgendwie so Fisher-Price-Technik, irgendwie so zwei zusammengelötete Mandarinen, die da irgendwie in dieser Plastikschale da drin waren. Und das war halt einfach eine fucking Playstation, die du mit dir rumtragen konntest, Playstation 1 Niveau. Und technisch absolut überlegen, riesiges Display. Und dann hat ein Schulkollege von mir tatsächlich eine PSP und hat da mal meinen DS so in die Hand genommen.
Also wirklich so, da gebe ich dem Kinderspielzeug auch mal eine Chance. Und dann meinte er, oh, stufenloses Sound einsteigen. Und ich dachte mir, oh, war mir gar nicht bewusst. Was heißt das denn? Was heißt das denn eigentlich? Das hat so einen ein Zentimeter langen Regler, den man so hin und herschieben kann, der ist stufenlos, wohingegen die PSP einfach so 20 Sound-Einstellungen hat. Aber jetzt mal eine Frage, weil mein neues iPhone suggeriert mir auch ein stufenloses, aber so funktioniert die Technik nicht. Sind wir nicht bei der Planck-Konstante oder so angekommen, dass es eigentlich kein stufenlos gibt? Eben, also ich meine, klar gibt's, nee, das stimmt nicht ganz, es gibt zwischen der Null und der Eins unendlich viele Zahlen, rationale Zahlen. Gut, du bist ja Mathematiker, ich bin ja Physiker. So, ja, ja, du wendest es an, du denkst es zu Ende in der Realität. Ich meine das genau, ich verstehe, was du meinst, als der Herr Physiker, der mir gegenüber sitzt, weil zwar gaukelt uns dieser Schiebregler, dieser kleine, unmenschlich zu bedienende Schiebregler, der auch immer nur auf ganz laut oder ganz leise war, nie war der woanders. Und recht schnell kaputt ist. Na klar. Der gaukelt uns vor, stufenlos zu sein, genau wie mein Handy gaukelt mir mit diesem stufenlosen Balken, der sich füllt, vor, stufenlos zu sein. Was ich glaube, in einer Welt von Nullen und Einsen, in der diese Computer-Teufelsgeräte ja denken, gibt es stufenlos nicht. Es gibt keine Stufen. Es gibt Stufen. Es gibt immer Stufen. Es gibt immer Stufen. Überall sind Stufen. Aber das mag ich sehr. Gaukelt mir doch bitte vor, dass ich die Kontrolle habe. Gibt sie mir nicht, bitte, auf keinen Fall. Gibt mir die Kontrolle nicht, aber gaukelt mir die maximale Kontrolle vor. Hier bei dem Tisch kann man zum Beispiel einstellen Zentimeter auf zwei Nachkommastellen. Also du kannst auf zwei Nachkommastellen die Zentimeterhöhe einstellen, mit der es dann hochfällt. Wenn es hoch geht, dann rattert es hoch und du denkst dir, das sind so viele Möglichkeiten. Ich werde wahrscheinlich nie zweimal am selben Tisch sitzen, wenn ich den jeden Tag bewege. Auf derart bin ich jetzt erleichtert, dass wir wieder die Kontrolle haben, zu entscheiden, wir setzen uns an diesem kleinen Tisch. Es wirkt so ein bisschen, als wären wir durchgefallen, wären wir die einzigen Schüler, die durchgefallen sind und zum dritten Mal jetzt die Brüche lernen, uns immer noch nicht so richtig. Warum ist ein Siebtel weniger als ein Sechstel? Das ist doch... Das ist nicht die Sieben, aber ich traue mich nicht zu fragen. Es ist diese Frage, ist Nullkommaperiode neun gleich eins? Meinst du, wir können die klären heute in der... Meine Frage ist, ist Nullkommaperiode neun nicht einfach eins ja ist es auch glaube ich
weil ein neuntel mal neun ist ja neun also was ist der nullkommaperiode eins ist ja ein neuntel Aber, aber kurz auf, 0, also, ein Neuntel ist Null Komma Periode eins. Das mal neun ergibt ja eins. Ein Neuntel mal neun ergibt eins. Das heisst, Null Komma Periode neun ist gleich eins. Quad erat demonstrandum, meine Damen und Herren. Da habt ihr schon mal den Audiobeweis gehört. Mathematisch ist noch nicht ganz fest, weil, glaube ich, Audiobeweise generell nicht angenommen werden. Also die Fieldsmedaille ist erstmal nochmal auf Halt. Die ist jetzt schon in irgendeinem Schliessfach, aber du kriegst sie ja nicht, weil du musst es niederschreiben. Nur die Schrift hat Dauer. Ich glaube, man muss es sogar da niederschreiben. Ich glaube, man muss es da niederschreiben, wohingegen das da niedersprechen völlig wertlos ist, absolut wertlos.
Sprechen ist nicht so, wer schreibt, der bleibt. Hat Dauer. Ich glaube, man muss es sogar da niederschreiben. Ich glaube, man muss es da niederschreiben, wohingegen das da niedersprechen völlig wertlos ist, absolut wertlos.
Sprechen ist nicht so, wer schreibt, der bleibt. Das ist dieser alte Leitsatz. Der hält noch stand.
Ja, das stimmt. Die Podcasts von den alten griechischen Philosophen sind alle weg, alle im Äther, alle irgendwo in irgendeinem Soundcloud-Account, den niemand mehr benutzen kann.
Weil das Passwort vergessen wurde.
Das Passwort ist vergessen. Herakles. Herakles und weil irgendwann die Kosten nicht mehr bezahlt wurden. Ich habe tatsächlich noch einen Podcast über Soundcloud laufen, bei dem ich glaube ich wirklich seit dutzenden Jahren jedes Jahr Geld zahle und ich überlege mir jedes Mal, lass ihn fallen, lass ihn fallen. Diesen alten, schäbigen Podcast, der noch rumhängt. Last September in Monaco. Und das ist noch so ein Überbleibsel, der noch mal so rumhängt, den man irgendwie, es gibt so gewisse Sachen im Haushalt, man zieht um und die sind immer noch dabei, obwohl man sie nicht dabei haben will. Man denkt sich, ah, die schmeisst sich irgendwann mal weg, aber man schmeisst sie nie weg. Und das ist so ein bisschen dieser Podcast auch, der einfach auf Soundcloud immer noch sein Dasein fristet.
Vielen Dank an Luca übrigens für das Intro.
Mal vergessen.
Mal fast vergessen.
Mal vergessen, aber er ist dabei. Luca ist am Start.
Luca mit K oder mit C?
Mit C. Luca.
Finde ich einen schönen Namen.
Ist sehr schön, ja.
Stell ich mir immer einen sehr schönen, tollen Menschen vor.
Sehr schönen Menschen vor.
Der irgendwie das Leben bei sich hat. Der macht dann auch noch Musik. hat einen tollen Job und so, ach fick dich doch, Luca. Tollen Job, sieht fantastisch aus, hat alles im Griff. Hat einen hohen Tisch, ey. Der hat einen richtig hohen Tisch. Der hat einen fucking hohen Tisch. Fick dich, Luca, ey. Der hat einen richtig hohen Stuhl auch, wo du wirklich auch als Gast kaum raufkommst, weil der einfach Dominanz zeigt. Ja, du hast die hohen Stimme. Big Chair Energy. Ja, ja, genau. Und das gefällt mir nicht, weil ich, auch wenn ich nicht den grössten Stuhl habe oder den höchsten Tisch habe, es kommt manchmal nicht darauf an, wie hoch dein Tisch ist, sondern was du darauf schreibst. Genau, richtig. Und manchmal ist ein verstellbarer Tisch auch wichtiger als ein grosser Tisch. Du musst dich anpassen können in der Situation. In manchen Situationen ist ein grosser Tisch vielleicht völlig über, zu gross. Völlig fehl am Platz. Da brauchst du dann eher einen niedrigen Tisch. Und nicht alle kommen mit grossen Tischen klar. Absolut. Und das ist deswegen so, ist die Frage, wenn du mit einem kleinen Tisch gut umgehen kannst, dann reicht es vielleicht auch einfach. Von daher, Luca. Hau ab. Hau ab einfach. Hau einfach ab, lass uns doch mal in Ruhe mit unserer Mittelmässigkeit. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt. Nein, wo dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand. Oh, das ist so schlimm, ich denke da so oft dran. Ich denke da so oft dran, dass du mir in Folge 3 davon erzählst. Ja, ja, von diesem Anti-Mobbing-Tanz, der mir tatsächlich von einem jungen Mädchen vorgetanzt wurde, die tatsächlich meinte, das wurde uns beigebracht, um Mobbern zu entgegnen. Und bis heute kann ich mir das kaum vorstellen, wie viele arme Kinder verprügelt wurden, weil sie diesen Tanz gemacht haben. Oder ist es wirklich so eine Art Vampirformel, dass der Mobber wirklich so geblendet getroffen ist, weil das wirklich einfach die magischen Worte sind, die den Mobber dann tatsächlich in die Schranken weisen kann.
Also für mich, der einzige Grund, warum ich mir vorstellen kann, dass es funktioniert, Hallo, Abstand, dieses Sassy-Abstand, ist glaube ich...
Jede Bewegung geht durch den ganzen Körper.
Wenn man das zu gross macht, dann hast du so einen TikTok-Tanz. Aber ich meine, der einzige Grund, warum ich mir vorstellen kann, dass es funktioniert, ist dieses, wie man angegriffen wird, zum Beispiel mit Messern, soll man ja auch... Mit mehreren Messern sogar. Zum Beispiel mit Messern. Mit wie vielen Messern? Ich stelle mir zwei Menschen vor, mit zwei Messern. Jeweils zwei Messer. Okay, vier Messer schnellen auf dich zu. Starren mir entgegen, der Mond blendet mich, weil er gespiegelt wird in den Messern. Ne, dunkle Gasse, wer alle kennt's, Nebel.
So, und im Hintergrund kennt's, Nebel.
So, und im Hintergrund Big Bang, Big Bang, Kirchenglocken, Big Ben, Jesus. Dann stehen die vier Messer mir entgegengesnellt und dann, habe ich mal gehört, soll man verrückt tun, so als wäre man verrückt. Und soll man die Hose runter machen zum Beispiel und sagen Mama oder sagen Quantenmechanik. Man sollte sie sozusagen aus ihrem Trott rausbringen. Aus dem Skript, das sie ja kennen. Oder zieh dein Shirt umgedreht an oder so oder dreh es einmal um oder dreh dein Shirt um den Arm herum. ärmel raus und dreht dein shirt oder dreh dich in dem shirt ohne dass das shirt sich bewegt das shirt bleibt auf der stelle und du rotierst aber und dabei sagst du trüffel salami trüffel salami und dann glaube ich ich glaube dann zerbrechen die messer plötzlich die klingen springen nee aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass es einechreckende Wirkung hat. A, wie sie treffen auf jemanden Unberechenbaren. Was mache ich jetzt? Es ist nicht nach Protokoll. A, wir suchen uns lieber ein Opfer, was uns einfach das Portemonnaie gibt. Und jeder weiss, dass Wahnsinn nicht physisch verletzt werden kann. Du kannst einen Stich, der Wahnsinn bleibt bestehen. Genau. Du hast keine Waffe mehr. Ja, der sticht mich ab. Genau, du hast, es ist undurchtet wie ein Geist. Es ist schwierig, mit Ratio gegen Irratio zu kämpfen. Macht da einen Schaden. Genau. Und deswegen, das ist, glaube ich, das gleiche Prinzip wie dieser Sassy-Tanz. Hallo, Abstand, hallo? Das würde auf mich eine ähnlich abschreckende Wirkung haben. Ja man ist so, meinst du das jetzt, viele Fragen, meinst du das ernst, warum tanzt du diesen Tanz? Warum kannst du so gut tanzen, also warum ist das so unglaublich geschmeidig? Dein Hüftschwung ist so awesome. Es ist so, ich habe kaum noch Möglichkeiten, dich zu treffen, weil du dich so geschmeidig bewegen kannst. Wir stellen uns vor, so eine Highschool-Opening-Scene, irgendwie so der ... Brrrring!
Genau.
Der Bäcker klingt. schmeidig bewegen kannst. Wir stellen uns vor, so eine Highschool Opening-Scene, irgendwie so der Kamera von oben fliegt auf die Schule herunter. Genau, so eine Amerika-Flagge da und du bist, sagen wir mal, Clarissa und Clarissa hat die Bücher natürlich vor sich und der Voice-Over sagt, so einem MGMT-artigen Song und dann sagst du so, mein erster Tag in der neuen Schule, alle waren hier reich, alle sind besser aussehend, alle sind schlauer, alle haben reiche Eltern, das habe ich alles nicht.
Aber alle haben sie Kickboards. Ich nehme mir vor, heute ist der erste Tag nach den Sommerferien, ich kriege das hin, alle haben Kickboards. Und dann kommt, da komme ich der Mobber an und sagst, und lauf an dir vorbei irgendwie mit meinem Jog-Shirt und Football-Shirt und mach dir die Bücher aus der Hand und die fallen rum und dann der Spind klappert dir gegen den Kopf und ich sag, ha, Loser mit deinem Kackbord und dann machst du den Tanz. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, mein Niveau, dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand. und holst das Messer raus.
Ziehen Klaresen sich die Hose runter und tanzen im Kreis.
Und dann ist der Film relativ schnell in Horror-Genre abgeht. Ja, Horror-Genre, als sie angefangen hat zu tanzen.
Ich dachte, dann ist er vielleicht so, das ist so schön getanzt.
Kann ich vielleicht eine Nummer haben? Ah, okay. Fünf. Wie fünf? Und dann stolziert sie weg. Und schon ist sie die Königin. Sie ist die Königin. Ich bin abgerutscht in Horror-Genre tatsächlich auf Instagram. Es gibt Instagram-Horror, so Mini-Horror-Stories, die so in Real-Form erzählt werden, irgendwie. das ist immer ein typ der ist immer in seinem haus und es sind immer irgendwelche komischen monster die von außen vom keller kommen oder so und es ist animiert es ist immer so eine person die so verzerrt ist die sie dann so ganz lang ist oder so einen verzerrten kopf hat oder so und ich weiss nicht ich mag horror nicht nicht, aber irgendwie bleibe ich da hängen. Und ich gucke die immer an mit so einem ganz stark geneigten Display. Also ich halte das Display fast in 90 Grad so vor mir hin, dass das Display sich in so einem kleinen Streifen verengt. Und ich denke, da kann nicht viel passieren, da kommt nichts. Das mache ich ganz leise und dann halte ich das so und dann so kuries ein paar Mal erst an und
dann traue ich mich immer näher ran,
weil ich dann trotzdem doch irgendwie Angst habe
oder so. Schwierig, wenn so ein kleines Mädchen
neben dem Zug sitzt und du drehst
den so genau zu ihr,
dass es für alle Außenstehenden so wirkt, als ob du
ihr das zeigen willst, diese Szene.
Und sie mit grossen Augen.
Völlig verstört einfach.
Aber es ist interessant, dass das auf Instagram, also da gibt es alles auch nochmal. Da gibt es dann nochmal so ein kleines Horror-Kuriositäten-Kabinett irgendwie, so eine kleine Geisterbahn, eine kleine Instagram-Geisterbahn, die es da auch gibt. Ich mag, das gibt so einen Kurzfilm, der ging jetzt auch so auf Instagram und so viral, so ein Abschlussfilm von dem Filmstudenten, The Portrait of God. Und der ist ganz cool, er ist über so ein Mädchen, Junge, weiß ich nicht mehr genau, irgendwie bereitet ein Referat vor und es gibt wohl dieses schwarze Bild, ist einfach ganz schwarz und das heisst The Portrait of God. Ich glaube, es ist sogar eine wahre Geschichte, es gibt dieses schwarze Bild, man soll ja kein Bild im Christentum sein, man soll sich kein Bild zeichnen vom Gott, das ist ja einer der Gebode. Gebode. Gebode. Von Moses Gebode. Ja, der Moses ist ein Gebode. Moses ist ein Gebode. Ja, sicher. Genau. Und dann gibt es das schwarze Bild und es gibt diese Geschichte, diesen Mythos, dass manche Leute, die da drauf gucken, sehen plötzlich irgendwann Augen. Und sehen dann plötzlich… Das ist ein 3D-Bild, oder was? Plötzlich sehen sie ein Gesicht, ganz dünn. Und alle Menschen, die das sehen, beschreiben unabhängig voneinander das gleiche Bild. Von so einem gruselig ausschauenden, dämonenhaften, eingefallenen Gesicht Fratzenmann. Und dann starrt sie da drauf, bereitet das Referat vor und sieht dann natürlich auch diesen Fratzenmann. Und Gott erscheint ihr. Aber du darfst Gott nicht, dann ist es so horrormässig. Aber das ist ziemlich cool gemacht. Da holt mich ja so ein bisschen ab, so ne. Ja, ja. Steigen wir jetzt in so eine Horrorwelt ab? Machen wir mal einen Horrorpodcast? Gruselcast. Mal so richtig, so einen richtigen, so einen Gänsehaut-Cast, wo wir dann wirklich so Geschichten erzählen und so eine Taschenlampe ins Gesicht, die Augen leiden. So macht man das, glaube ich, ja. Weil wir es auch nie gemacht haben, so die erste Folge direkt ins Gesicht und erzählen mal gruselige Geschichten. Ich glaube, das ist unser Horror. Unser Horror ist geblendet sein, so pragmatische Probleme. Ich mag es gar nicht, ich mag es tatsächlich echt nicht, geblendet zu sein. Ich glaube, das mag niemand so gern. Ich mag das gar nicht so. Also die Sonne gucke ich immer weg. Aber hast du dir mal so klischeehaft mit deinem Vater am Lagerfeuer so eine Gruselgeschichte? Nee, Gruselgeschichten. Ich fand es schon gruselig genug, unter Leuten zu sein, an einem Lagerfeuer und mir zu denken, so wann kann ich nach Hause, wann ist der frühestmögliche Punkt, nach Hause zu gehen, das war schon Horror genug, so da brauchst du gar keine Dämonen und Zombies mehr oder so. Ich war eher so der Witstyp, ich hab dann mir gerne Witze angehört. Ich kann keinen Witz. Ich glaub, die hab ich auch alle verdrängt, ich hab vergessen. Aber wäre das nicht ein Film, sozialer Horror?
So, dass man genauso Jumpscare-mässig
erzählt, wie jemand neben dir steht und fragt,
ob du noch mit ihm auf ein Bier
einen Absacker trinken willst.
Ja, ja, wir haben ja schon mal überlegt, so Erwachsenen-Horror-Filme,
so mit Steuern und so Formulare
und sowas in der Richtung, aber
das hat da nicht funktioniert. Einen Witz kenne ich. Okay. Also zwei, zwei Leute auf einer Party. Okay. Dann sagt der eine so, ich hasse diesen, dieses Witz-Dargon hasse ich schon so. Dann sagt der eine und niemand spricht so.
Der eine so, ähm, ah, hey, was machst du so? Was machst du so? Dann sagt der andere, ich studiere dual. Dann sagt der andere, okay, cool, aber hast du mich gerade Aal genannt? So, und den hast du dir gemerkt, weil du den A besonders schlecht fandest, weil der B besonders lustig? Ich fand den schon ganz gut. Dual, dual. Sind wir selber ausgedacht? Also, das Problem an Witzen ist die quälend lange unangenehme Stille danach. Ja. Und dass man nicht weiss, wann kann ich, also man hört ja so halb zu. Ich bin eher, ich bin eher bei mir immer, also ich bin eher darüber, denke ich darüber nach, ich will dem anderen jetzt gerade ein gutes Gefühl geben, beim Witz erzählen und möchte, egal ob es lustig ist oder nicht, möchte ich dem gegenüber zeigen, ich hätte die beste Zeit. Währenddessen höre ich aber nicht zu, weil ich unter so sozialem Druck stehe. Und dann verachte ich mehr auf den Moment, wann ich lachen kann. Und dann habe ich, mein Onkel hat mir meinen Witz erzählt und ich habe viel zu früh angefangen, scheinend zu lachen. Und er so, nee, warte mal, nee, warte mal. Als einziger. Und ich so, fucking hell, ich habe es verkackt, ich habe zu früh gelacht.
Ich habe den Cue, I misrapped the clues.
Ja, ja, das ist schwierig.
Mir kein Witz, der Guy.
Nee, ich auch nicht wirklich. Also ich kann wirklich einen.
Den jetzt?
Den jetzt, das war jetzt der eine.
Aber ich habe, ich will das jetzt nicht für alle, ich habe neulich eine sehr lustige Idee eines Witzes gehört, der Zwei-Stufen-Witz. Und ich kriege die jetzt nicht mehr zusammen, das machen sie nicht langweilig.
Das sind die absoluten Knallerwitze, die ich kriege jetzt nicht mehr zusammen, aber es gab einen Genie und dann so mit drei Wünschen und so, aber dann war der zweite Wunsch, der war dann irgendwie so, also mit so einem Teppich, oder was, ein Motorrad oder so was. Motorrad, Teppich, das sind die beiden Dinge, die... Nee, aber der warte irgendwo hin, aber dann kam er dann zu spät oder so. Aber das Prinzip ist zwei Stufenwitz, das ist, der erste fängt einen Witz an und dann kriegt er es aber nicht mehr so richtig zusammen und fängt so an so rumzzulabern und so, und will ich quälend lang, bis alle sagen, Alter, wirklich jetzt? Ah, jetzt fällt mir die Pointe nicht mehr ein, ist dann, sagt man dann, und die anderen sind natürlich alle mega sauer. Und dann kommt ein anderer Mensch, den man eingeweiht hat, zu einer Gruppe und sagt so, ah, er erzählt euch gerade Witze, und er erzählt dann auch einen Witz, der auch sehr unzusammenhängend wirkt, aber eine klare Pointe hat, die man alle erwartet, aber die Pointe, die er erzählt, ist die Pointe des Witzes, die man vergessen hat. Und dann sind natürlich alle mega amazed. Und das ist wirklich, und das hat mir Kuppel erzählt, wenn man das, glaube ich, richtig hinkriegt, ist das unfassbar lustig. Ich finde das eine gute Idee, so eine Art Flashmob-Witz, so dass du wirklich eingeweiht bist und dass es wirklich so eine Choreografie ist. Und der Erste erzählt den Witz und es ist quälend lang, hat keine Pointe, fällt ihm nicht mehr ein, dann kommt ein anderer dazu, erzählt einen ganz anderen Witz und man weiss genau, was die Erwartungshaltung ist und dann wird die Erwartung gebrochen, indem die Pointe, ist eine ganz andere Pointe, nämlich die vom ersten Menschen. Ja, ist gut, müsste man natürlich konkret nochmal ein bisschen ausarbeiten, im Comedy-Workshop einfach nochmal reingehen und daran schleifen. Aber ich finde die Idee gut. Das ist ja so wie bei so Zaubertricks, dass du so einen Kartentrick hast und dann ist die Karte, die du gesucht hast, aber am Fenster oder so. Und so, glaube ich, könnte man es auch machen. Erzählst einen Witz und die Pointe ist, dass jemand irgendwas ans Fenster wirft oder so. Ja, genau. Oder halt so von außen und du denkst dir, unabhängig vom Humor, allein der Organisationsaufwand, die Proben, die Choreo, das ist schon mal beeindruckend. Das ist, glaube ich, so die Idee. Deswegen, so sehe ich auch immer so Oper und sowas. Du musst so hart durch Produktion beeindrucken, dass du schon sagst, der Inhalt, die Geschichte ist egal. So die Geschichte von Don Carlos, na ja, so la la, aber der Umstand, die Produktion, das ist beeindruckend, da bin ich dabei, da gehe ich mit. Ja, angekommen, es hielt so einen Witz irgendwie, ja, kommt zwei Männer in eine Bar und so und hier ein Flummi dabei. Und ja, dann fangen die an mit so einem Flummi rumzuspielen und der Barkeeper sagt so, ne, hört mal auf mit dem Flummi rumzuspielen irgendwie. Aber die hört ja nicht auf, weil sie die lustig finden. Und plötzlich fliegt der Flummi raus und so der eine und der Barkeeper ist mega happy. Nee, pass auf, der Barkeeper nimmt den Flummi weg und wirft den aus dem Fenster und sagt so, das war's jetzt, ich halte das nicht mehr aus. Und dann tut man so, als ob man in die Pointe nicht mehr einfällt, und dann wirft dein Kumpel ein Flummi von außen ans Fenster. Okay. Und man checkt, ah, das ist der Flummi, den gerade der Barkeeper hinten rausgeworfen hat. Geil. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber woher weiss der Kumpel das dann? Gibt es dann so ein... Nee, du machst dein Handy, es ist... Du musst ein Schattenfellzeichen oder oder so was dass man sich ruft ne dein handy ist auf laut aber hast du vorher Tasche also präpariert da ist dein Handy kann das bitte einer von euch bitte machen einfach machen also ihr ruft euren Kumpel an Handy ist auf laut und macht in die Tasche Kumpel kann das Gespräch mit und, den Witz. Der erzählt den Barkeeper Flummi-Witz bei dem Mädel, was er beeindruckt hat. Wie gut kann man Gespräch
verfolgen, wenn das Handy in der Hosentasche ist? Funktioniert das? Häng dich da nachher
nicht fest. Weil ich habe nämlich Angst, dass ich der Kumpel draußen bin mit dem Flummi
in der Hand und dann so und ich in völliger Panik jetzt und einfach völlig Scheibe zerspringen von ihr, von dem Date. Noch bevor du überhaupt irgendwie angefangen hast, den Witz setzt. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem. Aber wenn Flummi eine Scheibe zerstört, bountst der dann weg, sodass er keine Spuren hinterlässt? Du bist heute ein Physiker. Ich bin heute wirklich ein Physiker. Du denkst physisch. Ich denke physisch. Gibt es einen Sweetspot an Geschwindigkeit, dass er einerseits die Scheibe zerbricht, aber auch wegbounced? Das ist ja immer so diese Sache mit, du schiesst auf eine Dose und wann fällt die D dose um und wann ist sie durchschossen also wenn du
jetzt die aufgabe ist die dose zu umzuwerfen und ich schiesse drauf und dann durchschiesse sie aber nur dann ist das ein problem dann musst du gucken wo ist der sweet spot das ist ein paradox was ich mir als kind überlegt habe ist wenn man wenn man mit der leiter runter fällt stell dir eine grosse leiter vor man ist oben drauf und die leiter fällt um wenn man früh genug abspringt Achso, ich dachte, man klettert die Leiter runter. Während die Leiter umkippt, kletterst du die Leiter runter. Schnell runter. Und dann am Ende bist du ganz unten und fällst nur so auf den Rücken. Ja, so rollst du dich so leicht ab und hast dann die Leiter in der Hand. Und dann finden deine Eltern dich im Garten und du liegst da, es sieht so aus, als ob du durch die Leiter guckst und dir hingelegt hast. Als ob du müde geworden wärst beim Aufstellen der Leiter und die dich einfach übermannt hat. Aber dein Gesicht sagt Panik. Und dann sagt Stefan, kommst du mal? Und du kriegst die Leiter nicht hoch, also kletterst du die Leiter wieder hoch und rutscht mit dem Rücken über den Boden und dann, wenn du ganz vorne angekommen bist, steigst du sozusagen aus und sagst, ja, was kann ich vielleicht tun? Pater, mater? Wir haben ein wunderliches Kind. Pater, mater, quill? Pater, mater, quill. Was kann ich tun? Wir haben ein wunderliches Kind. Ja, wie so die Schildkröten, ne? Also die bräuchten auch, wenn du so eine Schildkröte auf dem Rücken hast, die bräuchten auch so eine Leiter, dass sie dann damit sich noch bewegen können. Vielleicht werden sie damit sogar schneller. Ich denke mir bei Schildöten immer, wie dumm, du hast ja eine grosse Oberfläche unten, die du immer mitschleifen musst. Wohingegen oben ist, hast du so eine Halbkugel, die hat ja eine ganz geringe Oberfläche. Warum hast du nicht unten die Halbkugel, mit der du nur wenig Reibung hast und oben flach? Ich denke mir manchmal, Tiere, man will den Tieren ja einen Gefallen tun, langsamen Tieren wie Schildkröten oder so oder Schlangen, so langsame Tiere. Man will den Gefallen tun und dann zieht man den Rollschuh an. Ich glaube, manchmal hat es schon Sinn von der Natur, dass langsame Tiere langsam sind. weil stell dir mal vor du sind fault hier aber du aber du gibst ihm diese Samuel-Koch-Kängurusschuhe, damit die halt so ... Schlechtes Image mittlerweile, aber ... Ja. Ja, ein bisschen schade, weil die schon cool sind. Ja, wirklich, ja. Du, Zeppelin-Problem. Das Zeppelin-Problem. Yes, ich liebe dich dafür. Ich bin gerade im Zeppelin-Rabbit-Hole. Das ist eine gute Idee, aber leider durch einen katastrophalen Vorfall Imageprobleme bekommen, sodass es nicht weitergeht.
Ich bin so, ich habe die Hindenburg-Doku geschaut und bin jetzt wahnsinnig im Zeppelin-Rabbit-Hole. Ich liebe das. Wie amazing sind denn Zeppeline, bitte?
Ja, wie cool sind die denn?
Wie viele gibt es noch?
Zig!
Da merkt man, der Nachmittag hat sich gelohnt, den du in diese Doku investiert hast.
Sich.
Ne, Dutzende.
Unzählige.
Ja.
Wenn man nicht zählt.
Aber ich denke mir so, die sind relativ sicher, oder?
Weil ein Zusammenstoss von zwei Zeppelinen ist ja wahrscheinlich erst mal nur witzig.
Gar kein Problem.
Nur lustig.
Unglaublich lustig.
Klar, man verliert wahnsinnig viel Zeit, weil die erst mal und dann wieder auseinander und dann werden die getrieben in die andere Seite und dann müssen sie erst mal wieder Gas geben in die eigentliche Richtung, die sie wollten. So, so passen Sie auf, rechts, rechts kommt der Zeppelin, der andere Zeppelin, nein, nein, wir weich, schnell, wir stossen zusammen, wir haben aus der Titanic gelernt, frontal darauf zu. Okay, oh!
Der Zusammenstoss dauert einfach 20 Minuten.
Aber das wäre doch dein neuestes Event, TV-Total, Zeppelin-Ball.
Zeppelin-Crash-Challenge.
Und du einfach dann ganz viele Zeppeliner und dann so dich rausdrängen musst.
Die waren ja schon sehr sicher, es ist ein bisschen das Concorde-Ding. Aber dann gab es halt so ein paar Unglücke und dann war es eher ein Marketingproblem, glaube ich. Aber ich denke mal an Rüppel. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, du hast Saboteure generell oder halt einfach Kinder, die irgendwie dann Sachen aufs Gleis legen oder in so einem Quatsch. Die anfangen zu rauchen im Heliumraum. Genau, oder die halt einfach irgendwie mit ihrer Druckpistole von unten auf den Zeppelin schiessen. Der hält ja nicht wahnsinnig viel aus. Und dann kommen die, oder mit einer Drohne, du kannst ja eigentlich wahrscheinlich mit einer Drohne den Zeppelin wahrscheinlich komplett einfach zu Boden bringen. Und dann, klar, wenn der erstmal ein Loch hat, ist er für eine Zeit lang schneller. Aber dann hast du diesen Luftballon-Effekt, also so willst du auch nicht sterben, du willst nicht sterben, indem du in einem Gerät sitzt, was unkoordiniert durch die Gegend fliegt und alle drin so wow, aber dann tot leider, keine Chance mehr. Also ich glaube, Drohnen haben viel kaputt gemacht, was das angeht. Wusstest du, dass die Hindenburg, ich dachte ja, die wurde gebaut und ist dann schon verunglückt, ein bisschen. Die ist erst verunglückt und dann wurde sie gebaut. Ganz verrückt. In meinem Kopf hat die Hindenburg nicht lange Bestand gehabt. Ja. Hatte sie. Die hat, glaube ich, siebzehn Mal den Atlantik überquert.
Ach wow, aber darüber spricht niemand. Darüber spricht ja niemand. Man ist ja nur beim Unglück. Aber die hat siebzehn Mal, anders als die Titanic, die bei der Jungfernfahrt, bei der Jungfernfahrt verunglückt ist. Und Schiffe gibt es heute noch, obwohl das für ein Quatsch. Eben, richtig ja Quatsch, Jungfernfahrt verunglückt. Und der Zeppelin, die Hindenburg, ist super häufig über den Atlantik geflogen, von Frankfurt nach Manhattan. Was hat man da für eine Reisezeit? Tatsächlich 60 Stunden. 60 Stunden? Ja, es hat einmal in einer Rekordzeit von 61 Stunden die Strecke Frankfurt-Manhattan geschafft. Gar nicht schlecht. Und du hast ja super komfortabel, super komfortables Reisen. Also die hatten einigermaßen viel Platz, hatten geile Betten da, hatten tolle Restaurants, es gab so ein Musikzimmer, wo dann so die ganzen Nazi-Offiziere saßen und dann mit dem Musikzimmer Musik gehört, ihre die Smash-Hits. Ja, ja, klar. Radetzky-Marsch und sowas. Erika.
Sowas.
Und, aber dann hatten
die richtig geile Einrichtung, dann so richtig schicke
Sessel und so Salons
und die, oft war es wohl so,
dass die Passagiere den Start
nicht mitbekommen haben, weil das ist alles
so weich.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, ah shit, ich muss noch ganz
kurz zum Duty-Free-Shop und mir M&Ms.
Und da sind leider ganz viele Leute umgekommen. Genau, die haben den Start verpasst. Und dann kannst du dir auch den Kopf, du kannst das Fenster auch aufmachen und kannst rausgucken. Über dem Ozean. Es ist schon eine wahnsinnig coole Sache. Und dann gibt es wirklich so Bilder, wie dann dieser Zeppelin, die die grosse Hindenburg, über Manhattan schwebt. Und es sieht einfach wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig cool aus tatsächlich. Also immer abgesehen von dem Drecks Hakenkreuz und dem ganzen Nazi-Scheiss sind diese Zeppeline einfach wahnsinnig schöne, riesige majestätische Geschöpfe, die sowieso Wale, die Wale des Himmels, so wie ich da will. Und dann hast du ja diese Wolkenkratzer und oben quetscht diese Zeppelinen durch. Also Linienzeppelinen, die immer rumfliegen oder so fliegende Hotels oder so, wenn du dann einfach sagst, ich will gar nicht woanders hin, ich will nur in einem fucking fliegenden Hotel wohnen, das ist ja auch schon geil, für so eine Messe oder so, du hebst ab, dann machst du Gamescom auf dem Zeppelin und dann landest du wieder ansteigen aus. Das klingt wie so ein geilerer Cyberpunk-Film. Das Fliegenhotel. Das ist so ein Cyberpunk-Future-Film von uns. Sehr experimentell, aber es geht um das Fliegenhotel. Und das ist einfach ein grosser Zeppelin, der in der Zukunft immer nur, man kann auch nicht, der landet nie, sondern man kann nur mit kleinen Flugzeugen da andocken und aussteigen. Genau, weil in der Zukunft ist alles so vollgebaut, dass sozusagen die soziale Klasse nur von Höhe geregelt wird.
Also je höher du bist, desto sozial höher angesehen bist du und unten leben dann die ganzen Krebsmenschen und Maulwurstmenschen, die schon seit Jahrzehnten kein Sonnenlicht mehr gesehen haben, noch nie ein Sonnenlicht in ihrem Leben gesehen haben.
Und dann gibt es natürlich, okay, jetzt natürlich das Fliegenhotel, das höchste Hotelste hotel der welt wo natürlich alle die high society sagt da muss ich natürlich teil davon sein weil es höher ist alle gebäude im goldenen salon der goldene salon natürlich angestoßen und man sagt das bernsteinzimmer wurde dort wieder aufgebaut und alles ganz toll und wer ist da aber dann natürlich mord unglück saboteure saboteure an bord sabure schießen. Ein Maulwurfsmensch hat es geschafft an Bord, gräbt sich raus, gräbt ein Loch in den Zeppelin rein und dann Pfff. Und dann ist der Film vorbei. Ja, aber so ein Triangle of Sadness, Eat the Rich Film in einer Cyberpunk-Welt mit Hilberts fliegendem hotel ja okay zu viele ideen gleichzeitig ja hilberts unendliches fliegendes hotel okay also im ersten zimmer ist ein geist im zweiten zimmer sind zwei geister und wenn er keinen keinen Platz mehr hat, kriegt man, sagt der Hilbert, Portier sagt, kein Problem, wir haben noch ein drittes Zimmer, wir bauen immer noch eine Etage obendrauf. Ja, ja. Und dann bist du Mathematik, Grusel, Cyberpunk, Mash-Up. Ein Film für alle. Zielgruppe, alle! Ja, du pitchst einfach einen Film und sagst, ähm, Herr Tietze, eine Frage hätte ich noch. Wer soll denn diesen Film anschauen? Du hast jetzt einen Königsberg-Akzent jetzt drauf. Einfach Königsberg. Königsberg. Wer soll diesen Film denn anschauen wollen? Ja, alle. Für dich, der ist für dich der Film, der ist für dich, für dich, für alle. Aber ich habe einen Mathematik-Nobelpreis gewonnen, wie soll mich dieser Film unterhalten,
bitte?
Es geht, es ist eine Parabel auf Hilberts und ähnlichen Hotel.
Hilberts Hotel!
Ja, im Kern ist es das, was Netflix und Disney gerade alle wollen, ne?
Uuuuui!
Content für alle, Content für alle. Und ist es dann gut? Ich glaube nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, wo ich dich damit will. Aber das, also ich hatte da sehr viel Spaß dran gehabt an dieser, an diesen Dokus. Und jetzt werden wieder viele Zeppeline gebaut in Friedrichshafen der Zeppelinstadt, wo ja auch die Zeppelin-Universität ist und Graf von Zeppelin, damals hat die ja gegründet und baute diese Luftschiffe und die sind jetzt wieder sehr wichtig, weil zum Beispiel in Katastrophengebieten kommst du nicht hin mit Helikoptern unbedingt, wenn er, weiss ich nicht mehr genau warum.
Was für ein Katastrophengebiet genau? Naja, also Erdbebengebiete oder sowas. Ist total gut mit, zum Beispiel zu observieren mit Zeppelin, weil die sind viel, die können einfach, denen ist alles scheiss egal, die brauchen noch nicht viel Platz zum Landen, Oh nein, ein Erdbeben! Die sind leise. Ey, das ist mir gerade so scheißegal. Sorry, es ist mir so scheißegal gerade. Oh nein, der Wettebericht sagt, in zwei Stunden, ein riesiger Taifun trifft die Küste. I could not care less. Aber ich finde es so gut, weil wenn du sagst Graf von Zeppelin, Zeppelin ist ja erstmal ein fantastisches Wort, PR, absolut geil, aber dann finde ich ja geil, im Amerikanischen heisst das Ganze Blimp. Nein. Blimp. Nein, nicht Blimp. Zeppelin heisst Blimp. Nein, ja auch. Blimp. Luftschiff. Ich weiss auch nicht, woher das kommt, aber es ist einfach Blimp. Oh nein. Und da denke ich mir, wenn der Graf Zeppelin seine Erfindung da durch die ganze Welt bringt und dann sagt, ah, Herr Zeppelin, Sie haben doch den Blimp erfunden. Bitte, bitte, bitte was? Zeppi, den Zeppi. Nein, den Zeppelin. Den Zeppelin. Ja, ja, Blimp. Nein, den Zeppelin. Nee, wir sagen Blimp. Den Zeppelin. Blimpi. Blimpi-babbli-bubbli-bam.
Ich wäre fast auf die Zeppelin-Universität gegangen.
Ich war nämlich mal in einer Phase, ich habe meine Kindheit quasi verschwendet mit dem Bemalen von Plastikfiguren und unsinnigen Disputen zum Thema Cityroller-Kickboard. Und irgendwann war dann unser Freundeskreis, die wir nur keine Zukunftsmöglichkeiten gesehen haben oder uns nicht so viel dafür interessiert haben, gab es dann irgendwann so eine Berufsorientierungsmesse und dann sind wir da mal so alibimässig hingegangen.
Und da gab es dann verschiedene Universitäten, die sich vorgestellt haben, unter anderem die Zeppelin-Universität. Und da waren wir dann und da hieß es, ja, bei uns ganz innovatives Konzept, bei uns gibt es keine Professoren, sondern die Studenten lehren sich gegenseitig.
Bis heute habe ich es nicht verstanden. Ich habe mich selbst, als ich auf der Messe war, nicht dafür interessiert.
Sehr schön, dass Sie sich für unsere Kita interessieren. Erstmal schön, dass Sie sich so früh kümmern, um Kita-Platz und so, ist sehr wichtig.
Genau, wir haben ein bisschen anderes Prinzip. Wir sind auch die Einzel Kita mit noch Plätzen frei. Wir haben ein bisschen experimentelles Prinzip.
Ach genau, wir waren schon bei vielen verschiedenen. Unsere kleine Fiona ist jetzt schon im Alter für die Kita. Und da sind wir echt froh, dass wir jetzt noch einen Platz gefunden haben. Ja genau, wir haben ein bisschen anderes Prinzip als andere Kitas. Oh okay, super. Eher so Montessori in die Ecke, so Homöopathie. Wir erziehen die Kinder nicht, sondern die Kinder erziehen sich selber. Das heißt, wir sperren die in den Raum. Hier habe ich den Schlüssel in der Hand. Und jetzt sind die Kinder gerade gekommen hier. Das ist gerade Henrik, der kleine Henrik ist gerade das letzte Kind heute. Danke, ich kann kurz die Eltern verabschieden. Und dann mache ich, ich würde kurz die Tür zumachen und einfach hier abschliessen. Genau, und die sind ja einfach drin. Genau, sind die drin und die Tischkanten sind abgerundet und das Besteck, mit dem sie ihr selbst gemachtes Essen, die Zutaten liegen da rum, die können schon irgendwas machen, oft kommt nichts bei rum, aber sie müssen es halt lernen. Kann ich da mal reinschauen? Ja klar, wir haben hier diese Gucklöcher, die ist sehr spannend. Oh mein Gott! Oh mein Gott, das ist ja schrecklich! Das ist ja schrecklich! Oft haben wir wir draußen mehr Leute, die da reingucken, als Kinder, die drinnen sind. Die Elfte der Kinder sind tot! Ja, klar, also ich meine, natürlich, im echten Leben da draußen gibt es nicht nur Leben, Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen, sondern da draußen gibt es Tod und Mord und schlimme Dinge. Und hier ist die Idee, es ist aus der Not entstanden. Ich kann hier mal die Geschichte sagen. Ach so, es ist aus der Not entstanden, wir hatten dann immer kein Geld. Das klingt natürlich gut. Das war mir natürlich zu hören. Diese wahnsinnig tolle Idee ist aus der Not entstanden, dass wir keine Erzieher bezahlen konnten. Ach so, wir hatten kein Geld. Und deswegen, ja klar, na ja, es gibt ja sonst keine Kita, von daher nehme ich das an.
Okay.
Dieser Sketch wurde Ihnen präsentiert vom Kultusministerium für Erziehung, Kinder, Rentner.
Wir haben Sie eine Kita. Jetzt.
Wir haben einen Erzieherinnenmangel.
Werden Sie Erzieherin.
Jetzt.
Morgen ist es vielleicht schon zu spät.
Heute Nachmittag ist es vielleicht schon zu spät. Jetzt. Bewerben Sie sich lieber jetzt. Und dann hatten wir noch einen Termin bei einer anderen Universität und da waren wir ein bisschen zu spät und der Hörsaal war schon komplett voll und es gab nur noch Plätze in der ersten Reihe. Also sind wir, ein Freund von mir und ich, in die erste Reihe gegangen und dann haben wir alle gewartet, Universiteta Bocconi und dann ging es endlich los, die Tür sprang auf, eine Frau kam rein und fing an,
und hat wirklich 90 Minuten für Italienisch ihren Vortrag gehalten.
Und wir beide sassen in der ersten Reihe, mussten uns erst mal lachen, verkneifen,
weil wir einfach die grössten Vollidioten der Welt sind.
Aber ja, dann haben wir den Raum wieder verlassen, ohne allzu viel gelernt zu haben über die Universität da Bocconi.
Aber bis heute ist es so ein Running Gag bei uns, dass wir eines Tages gerne nochmal in die Universität da Bocconi gehen würden, wo wir einfach nochmal sagen, da hätten wir so viel lernen können, aber es ist leider nichts geworden. Bocconi Milano Universität. Milano Universität, das ist klar. Das ist die Wissenschaftsuniversität Luigi Bocconi. Wer war Luigi Bocconi? Wer war der Mann? Die Universiteta Comerciale Luigi Bocconi übersetzt Wirtschaftsuniversität Luigi Bocconi? Also pass auf. Wer war der Mann? Die Università Comerziale Luigi Bocconi, übersetzt Wirtschaftsuniversität Luigi Bocconi, befindet sich im Zentrum von Mailand. Oh, er hätte wirklich ein spannendes Leben gehabt, in der Via Lebellini. Sie ist eine im Jahre 1902 gegründete private Wirtschaftsuniversität und bietet Englisch sowie Italienischsprachige Studiengänge im Bereich der Wirtschafts- und Rechtswissenschaften an.
Ein Ranking der Financial Times hat sie im Jahr 2022 als eine der zehn besten Business Schools Europas eingestuft. Ich könnte so viel Geld haben jetzt, ey, wirklich, stell dir vor, ich hätte da in Mailand schön Wirtschaft studiert
und könnte jetzt wirklich an den Hebeln der Welt Devisen, Aktien, Erpapier, Quants, nach links und rechts, Geld, maximal, Kapitalwirtschaftung. Angelo, Angelo, überweist mir nochmal zwei Miller aus Lichtenstein. Si, si, si. Angelo, Angelo, sind die Sankt-Moritz-Depots schon fertig? No. Angelo, ruft doch nochmal bei der Melissa an. Komme und kümm dich da noch mal um die Schweizer Banken. Wir haben da noch so ein Wertfach, Wertfach 5515, geh da noch mal hin, da ist Platin, da sind Platinplatten drin. Hol die Platinplatten aus der Züricher Bank und bring sie nach Frankfurt, bring sie nach Frankfurt an die Börse. Angelo, der Platinpreis geht durch die Decke, Angelo, tu es, das Leben. und du sagst, kommst nach Hause zu einer steinreichen Frau mit deinen steinreichen Kindern, deinen steinreichen Menschen und sagst, ich halte die Italiener nicht aus. Sie haben mir so viel geschenkt, aber sie haben mir auch so viel genommen in meinem Leben. Das ist kein Problem. Nochmal, man darf sich über Italiener witzig machen. Das ist der letzte Akzent, über den man sich lustig macht.
Wer ist Luigi Bocconi?
Die Wirtschaftsuniversität de Luigi Bocconi wurde als Stiftung von, jetzt kommt ein Curveball, von Ferdinando Bocconi, einem reichen Mailänder Kaufmann gegründet.
Das klingt so gut.
Der mit der Hochschule seinem am 1. März 1869 in der Schlacht von Adva gefallenen Sohn Luigi Bocconi ein Denkmal setzen wollte.
Die Wirtschaftsuniversität Mailand war die erste italienische Universität, die einen Abschluss in Ökonomie ermöglichte.
Der Vater, Ferdinando Bocconi, hat Luigi Bocconi seinem Sohn diese Uni gewidmet.
Und der ist in einem Wirtschaftskrieg gefallen, oder was haben die mit ... In einem Wirtschaftsschlacht, in einem Bearhug umgebracht worden, der mit der Hochschule an seinem 1. März in der Schlacht von Adwa. So, jetzt kann man natürlich ... Du willst nicht in der Schlacht fallen, die keiner mehr kennt, oder? Adua. Die Schlacht von Adua war eine militärische Auseinandersetzung zwischen den Äthiopischen Armee unter Negus Negest und Kaiser Menelik II. gegen Invasionstruppen des Königreichs Italien. Äthiopien gegen Italien? Auch ein Kampf, den man so noch nicht am Schirm hatte. Wow, krass. So, jetzt mache ich die Italiener nach. Okay, so, da würde ich gerne meine Doku sehen. Das wäre vielleicht nochmal was für Antenne Afrika, Äthiopien. Gegen Italien. Dass man da nochmal sagt, die militärische Geschichte Äthiopiens, was da alles los war. Das Königreich Italien, das Kaiserreich Abyssinien. Boah, das ist ja super spannend. So wenig Ahnung. Da bist du doch in History-Bach.
Ich weiss nix, ich weiss nix. Ich weiss gar nix. Ich weiss. Aber wollen wir mal so Special-Folgen machen, in denen wir vielleicht ... Ich vergesse es alles. Das ist Podcast-Sufo-History. Allein mit diesem scheiss Konvex-Konkav-Bullshit und so, da bin ich schon immer auf. Okay, das ist ein anderes Thema. Einfach, aber ich denke mir so, ey, bevor du nicht konvex, konkav verstanden hast, lass mal gerade den Äthiopischen Krieg mal beiseite, also konzentrier dich auf die Basics. Flotin, Wissen ist nicht das Wissen, das ist ein anderer Bereich, Fachbereich. Und dann schaust du in den Spiegel und das Spiegelbild wird manchmal gedreht, manchmal nicht, manchmal spiegelverkehrt, manchmal auf dem Kopf, da bin ich schon raus. Ich bin einfach raus. Konkav von Lateinisch so, da kannst du ja merken, konkavus gewölbt, nach innen gewölbt. Ja, natürlich ist gewölbt, wohin? Natürlich ist gewölbt, ist irgendwo, ist immer gewölbt. Fucking Wölbung auch. Konkav von Lateinisch gewölbt, Ja, wow. Und konvex von Lateinisch gewölbt ja wow und konvex von lateinisch gewölbt ja geil danke
latein du hast uns mal wieder wirklich einen bärendienst erstattet fucking tote sprache zu
recht gestorben zu recht ermordete sprache verreckte sprache verreckt einfach verhungerte
ermordete erstochene sprache völlig zu recht latino mortos ist und dann warte bei luigi boconi
Ich bin... verhungerte, ermordete, erstochene Sprache, völlig zu Recht. Oh Gott, okay. Latino mortus est.
Und dann wartet er bei Luigi Bocconi.
Luigi Bocconi!
Und dann wartet er in der Vorlesung, hat er komplett durchgemacht.
Aber durchgemacht, weil wenn du in der ersten Reihe sitzt, so vor allem, du kannst nicht nach 20 Minuten aufstehen, so du kannst sofort aufstehen.
Es gibt kein gutes Timing, wo man wirklich aufsteht und geht, so aus der ersten Reihe. Also, wik, wik, wik, wik, wik, wik, wik, wik, wik, wik,el auch. Das heißt, es werden die kompletten Hörsagen. Und der andere Kumpel, der immer sagt, dass halt die ganze Kombination... Ja, wir waren ein weirdes Duo, aber er ist ein cooler Typ auf jeden Fall. Aber Wahnsinn, okay, weil da gibt es wirklich... Ihr könnt so froh sein, dass ihr euch nicht angesprochen habt. Vor allem ist es halt immer so, klar, ich will jetzt gar nichts gegen diese Universität sagen, aber du denkst dir, bei diesen Berufsorientierungstagen, da sind ja nicht die coolsten. Da geht er nicht Harvard hin und sagt, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte,, dass es eine tolle Uni ist.
Ja.
Aber wer Werbung machen muss auf solchen schmierigen Veranstaltungen?
Ich war ja mal werbender auf einer schmierigen Veranstaltung.
Ja?
Für deine Uni, oder was?
Für meine Uni, die, machen wir uns nichts vor, dringend nötig hatte, auf diese Messen zu gehen und Leute zu werben. Das ist komplett leer, oder was? Das habe ich schon mal erzählt, da bin ich ja umgefallen. Wie, du bist umgefallen. Du warst so erschlagen. Ich bin hingeschlagen. Okay, ihr wisst, welche Folge ihr jetzt nochmal aus dem Archiv rausholen könnt. War es Hinschlagen? Blättert die Kartei nochmal durch. Nee, ich meine, Hinschlagen war die Folge, wo du hingeschlagen bist. Ach, das kann sein, ja, ja. Das war so ein aufblasbarer Sitzwürfel und so. Und dann habe ich mich da so cool draufgelehnt, während ich mit Eltern darüber gesprochen habe, dass unsere Uni so toll ist. Und dann ist er so weggeflutscht und ich bin einfach aufgeklatscht. Das war so albern. Das war so schlimm für mich. Aber das ist doch, diese Tage machen dann auch so Mürbel.
Moment mal, aber die Eltern, die standen?
Die standen und du saßt auf diesem Gummiwürfel? Nee, wir standen, da war so ein Pult und daneben war so ein Gummiwürfel und da habe ich mit den Eltern gesprochen und so Flyer in die Hand gedrückt und erzählt, wie toll diese Uni ist und wie qualitativ hochwertig und bla bla bla bla. Und währenddessen habe ich mich so mit dem einen Knie so auf diesen auf diesen Würfel gelehnt. So und dann ist der aber, habe ich zu viel Gewicht genommen auf meinem linken Knie und dann ist er so weggerutscht, so einfach so weggeflogen, in den Raum reingeflogen und dann bin ich hingeschlagen. Aber das heisst, du standest hinter dem Pult, das heisst für die Erwachsenen sahst du aus, als würdest du einfach hinter dem Pult einfach runterrauschen und einfach weg sein.
Ja, zur Seite wegkippen so. Und das war so albern und schlimm und demütigend.
Ja.
Und ich glaube mal, ich lehne mich nicht aus dem Fenster, wenn ich sage, dass deren Kind nicht an der Uni studiert, obwohl es vielleicht eine coole Idee gewesen wäre. Ja. Und was waren das für Eltern? Das war Bridget und James Musk. Und Elon Musk hätte an der Uni Köln studieren können. Und vielleicht sähe unsere Welt dann anders aus. Besser oder schlechter? Das müsst ihr entscheiden. Der Würfel war übrigens konkav.
Also man muss sich eine sechseitige Koncave... Ich habe jetzt auch so einen Sitzball.
Ich habe auch so einen Sitzball.
Warum auch so einen?
Naja, wie so einen Sitzwürfel.
Aber Sitzwürfel ist natürlich eine gute Idee, aber ich habe jetzt auch so einen Sitzball, habe den schnell aufgepumpt, richtig bar reingeballert einfach.
Ich wollte den so richtig prall einfach so einen Prallball haben.
Und es macht richtig Spaß.
Das Problem ist, ich glaube, das ist nicht... Also mal ganz kurz an die Optiker da draußen, Augenärzte aufgepasst, unsere neue Kategorie an den Augenart. Augenärzte aufgepasst, passt, passt, passt schon. Und zwar bin ich jetzt, ich bin vielleicht ein bisschen wild auf dem ball aber ich gebe da gut gas also ich gebe glaube ich eine sprunghöhe von einem meter also von unterschied hoch und runter ist es denn schlecht für die augen wenn man während dessen film schaut oder was auf dem laptop so ein video anguckt oder so und währenddessen da so rumbau und zwar einerseits denke ich mir die augen sind ja Bälle, die dann versetzt wiederum da träge herumbouncen.
In deinen Augenhöhlen.
In den Augenhöhlen da rumkullern die ganze Zeit, währenddessen schauen die ja, müssen die immer wieder anpassen, ist es ein Problem oder ist es okay?
Was sagen die Optiker da draußen? Das war unsere Rubrik. Wa, wa, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, so einem Gymnastikball, mit so einem Sitzball, richtig gross.
Und ein größeres Tor?
Weil, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich habe nicht viel Fussball gespielt in meinem Leben, aber ich war ab und zu auf dem Boysplatz mit Kumpels und so.
Und ich war immer absolut mangelhaft bis ungenügend im Dribbling, aber passabel im Schuss.
Und seitdem suche ich einen Sport, wo ich nicht durch Dribblings neutralisiert werden kann, sondern wo ich wirklich zum Schuss komme. Und ich denke mir, in Grossball, du kannst ja nicht richtig dribbeln mit so einem riesigen Ball. Du musst halt wirklich gute Pässe übers Felde, links, rechts die Flanken belegen und dann ins Zentrum und dann spielst du natürlich über die Flanken, Mitte, links, die Tiefe, rein, so, die Z-Achse. Am Sechzehner ist dann aber auch Feierabend, um zu Abschluss zu kommen. Zum, ja, Kopfball. Und deswegen dachte ich, Grossball ist das vielleicht. Ich würde gerne mal so Events organisieren oder das grosse Promi-Grossball-Event, Guido ruf an, Steven Geltchen ruf an, ansonsten veranschaute ich selbst.
Das wäre natürlich geil, das ist ja gerade so diese Baller League und so, es gibt ja diese Twitch-Events von Lukas Podolski und Toni Kroos.
Das ist nämlich das Ding, und jetzt denkt man wirklich wie ein Medien-Arschloch, ich denke mal wie ein Medienwichser.
Ich denke jetzt mal einmal wie ein Medienwichser.
Wo schauen die Leute heutzutage Content? Ähm, im Kino. Ähm, von den Filmerkästen. Fast? Von den Radio an den Radio-Geräten. Handy, Smartphones. Handys. So. Und was ist das Problem mit dem Smartphone?
Knöpfe.
Kleiner Bildschirm.
Akkus.
Ja.
Und der Fussball ist gross.
Vergleichsweise klein.
Ah.
Ich hab schon ...
Ich hab schon normal, wenn man mal irgendwie zur WM oder so Fussball glotzt,
wenn man ein bisschen Fusi sich reinstäubt in die Augen,
hab ich schon immer Schwierigkeiten,
dem Ball zu folgen. Deswegen ist
er noch schwieriger, wenn du die Baller League schaust,
auf einem kleinen Display. Deswegen, der Ball
muss grösser werden, je kleiner
das Display wird. Wenn der Ball riesengross
ist, der Ball ist hüfthoch, kannst
du auch locker auf dem Handy anschauen,
kein Problem. Aber er nimmt es dann nicht den ganzen
Handybildschirm ein, der Ball.
Der Ball nimmt einen grösseren Teil des Bildschirms ein, richtig, aber der Ball ist ja die wichtigste Information. Wo ist der Ball gerade? Wo ist der Ball? Das ist das grosse Problem des Fussballs, ne, wo ist der Ball? Wo ist er? Ja. Denk mal drüber nach, denk mal drüber nach. Was ich mag, und ich will jetzt auch nicht, eigentlich will ich nicht Amateure sehen, die gegeneinander spielen, sondern ich will, will ich Real Madrid gegen Bayern München sehen mit einem riesigen Ball. Ja, genau. Und dann müssen die sich überlegen, wer hat die beste Strategie. Weil dann müssen natürlich die Tore, und ich dachte vielleicht, weil du jetzt sagst, ja Moment, aber wenn das Tor gleich gross ist, schießt du nie ein Tor mit dem grossen Ball. Deswegen sag ich, zwei Tore. Zwei Torwarte. Ähm, nee, zwei Tore. Und die stehen aber nicht direkt aneinander, sondern mit so einem zwei Meter Abstand, so dass die Mitte ist kein Tor, dann kommen die Tore, so dass der Torwart immer entscheiden muss, in welchen der beiden Tore bin ich gerade, so dass immer ein Tor offen ist für einen unerwarteten Weitschuss, weil der Ball ist ja auch ziemlich langsam, wenn der so gross ist, das heißt der unerwartete Weitschuss ist immer eine Option in das unbesetzte Tor.
Da kannst du mal antäuschen.
Ich finde das war geil.
Ich finde ihn mega gut.
Ich habe auch Formel 1 geguckt wieder.
Miami?
Ich will Miami.
Und ich will ja eigentlich die mal in anderen, also beim Fußball habe ich gedacht, gibt es ja noch den DFB-Pokal, Champions League, es gibt einfach Konstellation.
Und dann vor allem internationale Wettbewerbe, wo du halt die oft Spieler verschiedener Mannschaften in den Nationalmannschaften lassen, die dann antreten kannst. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr alles durch, mischt alles durch und hast irgendwie neue coole Zusammenstellungen. Das fehlt mir bei Formel 1. Es sind immer die gleichen Leute, oft in den gleichen Teams und die fahren eine Saison und dann ändert sich ein bisschen was.
Aber so, wenn die jetzt mal alle, wie Formel 3 zum es sind immer die gleichen Leute, oft in den gleichen Teams und die fahren eine Saison und dann ändert sich ein bisschen was, aber so, wenn die jetzt mal alle wie Formel 3 zum Beispiel mit den gleichen Autos, mit den gleichen Motoren und mit den Karosserien fahren würden und dann packst du noch David Coulthard rein und Jano Trulli und Heinz-Harald Frenzen, die alten Leute und so und dann will ich mal sehen, wer fährt eigentlich noch, wer fährt eigentlich am besten. Ja, so ein Super Smash war das mässig. All-Star-League mit so mit den ganzen Formel-1-Leuten.
Ja, ich war ja ein grosser Fan von Drive to Survive, der Netflix-Formel-1-Doku. Und da gibt es jetzt auch eine Nesca-Doku, die ja immer im Kreis fahren. Und ganz weirder Sport, der mir leider nicht gut vermittelt wurde, habe ich das Gefühl. Ich habe mich nicht ins Boot geholt gefühlt. Ich war nass im Wasser und ich habe nicht gecheckt, was ist da überhaupt, worum geht es da überhaupt, wenn du immer nur im Kreis fährst und die Autos sind auch alle gleich, also die sind wirklich alle genormt. Was macht man überhaupt als Fahrer? Ich will denen keine Fähigkeit in Abrede stellen, überhaupt nicht, das sind bestimmt tolle Sportler, aber ich habe es nicht gecheckt. Habe ich ausgemacht, da habe ich eine Folge Simpsons geguckt, dann wusste ich aber nicht mehr, in welcher Staffel ich bin, dann dachte ich mir, guck nochmal in Digimon rein, hab Digimon geschaut und dann dachte ich mir, wie wär's nochmal wieder mit einer Folge Lucky Luke, dann musst du aber auf Netflix Kids gehen und dann war ich bei Netflix Kids, Lucky Luke hat mich auch nicht mehr abgeholt. Okay. Man verschwendet den Nachmittag. Ich will kurz noch sagen, das hat mich gerade inspiriert mit dem grossen Ball, weil ich dachte, Formel 1, aber die jetzigen Fahrer in den jetzigen Teams fahren so Tri-Cars, wo man so trampeln muss, was man sich im Urlaub manchmal geliehen hat, am Kind an der Ostsee bin man ein Tri-Car geliehen, vorne ein Rad, hinten zwei Räder und dann trampelt man. Ja, und dann fahren die um Silvers dauernd. Und eine Runde dauert vierzehn Stunden. Ne, das will ich sehen. Finde ich gut. Wer kann am besten strampeln. Auch da geht es darum, wer ideal in der Linie fährt. Absolut. Auch da musst du Manöver, auch da Reifen wechseln, natürlich. Reifenabrieb ist ein Riesenthema. Musst du gucken, weil du sagst zwei Tore, bei mir gibt es zwei Zielflaggen. So, gut, finde ich gut. Leute, wie gesagt, wir haben Ideen. Meldet euch gerne mal, falls ihr den Podcast überhaupt hört, damit wir mal wissen, ob überhaupt was ankommt. Also damit wir vielleicht mal gucken, an wen wir da pitchen können. Ansonsten Tele5, Sat1, Pro7, ARD, Arte, Reisat, Ruft ante, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate, Ate,